in today's eight on your side
fever-reducing medications available in
liquid formulas for kids continue to be
difficult to find in town in many parts
of the country today eight tips for
navigating the Children's Tylenol and
motion shortage
surging demand in kids Tylenol due to a
significant increase in flu RSV and
covid continues to create bare shelves
in the kids aisle at our area pharmacies
and grocery stores Dr Carrie wijay
singha of Siena Pediatrics doesn't know
when this situation is going to change I
kind of equate it to the formula
shortage and I think things are going to
slowly come back over time a big
frustration for parents if you can't
find kids Tylenol or Motrin here are
eight tips to navigate first off do not
give adult Tylenol or Motrin to kids
under the age of 12. do search for
generic versions if you see generic
acetaminophen or Ibuprofen that is
acceptable you know there's different
forms of that there's chewable tabs some
dissolve don't use aspirin and avoid
giving multi-ingredient over-the-counter
medication as some of the other
ingredients can have unwanted side
effects in children ask a friend or
neighbor if they have any extra
children's over-the-counter medication
remember that not not all fevers need to
be treated with medicine dress your
child in light loose clothing be sure
they're well hydrated Dr Vijay singha
says a fever is the body's way of
fighting an infection and a bath can
help just remember if you want to lower
temperature and you just don't have
Tylenol or ibuprofen dosing there with
you or don't have the medicine a
lukewarm bath so not too hot not too
cold that would be bad too but a
lukewarm bath is like a really good
guidance for people too she urges
parents to go to this website
healthychildren.org from the American
Academy of Pediatrics you can Google
dosing it breaks it all down by weight
and age in the various forms
and the final eighth tip for you this is
also a great time to teach your kids to
swallow pills as it allows for more
flexibility during drug shortages